this youtuber has already raised a
hundred thousand dollars from his fans
by selling his youtube channel and it's
turning out to be a huge scam and i'm
here to tell you why let me start by
saying i'm a fan of this youtube channel
which kind of makes this a bit of a
weird story because i've reached out to
them in the past and said how much i
like their work it's a channel called
disrupt who you may have come across
they have 1.4 million subscribers and
their creator jack produces many
documentaries about everything from
computer viruses to hackers and if
you're a nerd it's pretty great stuff
but today jack posted something
different from his normal videos
he's selling his channel i am selling
this channel
well a portion of it because a change
is coming path a
and path b
path a i believe is the best option this
is the equity crowdfunding path
this means that right now at this
present moment you can own a portion
of disrupt for a minimum of 100
you will receive 23 shares of the
disrupt corporation
in return you'll get a percentage of the
net profit that this channel makes every
single year so right from the start this
all sounds pretty interesting right you
invest a hundred dollars you get a
portion of a youtube channel it's sort
of like buying a business and it's sort
of like supporting a creator that you
like you might be tempted to think it's
the best of both worlds i mean just
listen to all the cool stuff he plans to
use the money for and in return my team
and i will use that capital to expand
the disrupt operation and bring you
feature like films shows and virtual
reality content it's a compelling pitch
you're making money and he's gonna spend
your investment on better videos it's a
win-win right now jack does mention a
second path if he doesn't raise the full
amount but he pretty quickly labels that
a bad idea path b is the path that will
have to go down if we do not reach our
funding goal by the deadline
this would mean a complete restructuring
of the internal operations here at
disrupt
this path is not ideal
so if you want to secure the future of
the disrupt down path a
please consider investing now this is
where the first cracks in his story
start to show he never tells us what
path b is or why he'd have to take it in
fact he kind of does this weird appeal
of both hey on the one hand this is a
really serious investment and on the
other hand if you don't invest as a fan
your favorite channel could die which is
really weird but you might not notice it
watching the rest of the video you might
get swept away by all the beautiful
graphics which sort of serve as an
advertisement for what you're gonna get
if you help invest in the channel but
things really go sour when we actually
go to invest and we go to the website
where we invest at because that's where
we learn things aren't as advertised
let's start with the amount he's raising
five hundred thousand dollars for ten
percent of his channel the website
claims that disrupt is valuing
themselves at 10.7 million dollars
that's what they're claiming percent of
their company
is worth now this is absolutely insane i
own a channel of a similar size and
there's no way right you could argue my
channel is worth 10 million 10 million
10 million dollars okay well
technically if you ignore the 10 million
studio there's no way that my youtube
channel by itself is worth 10 million
okay i guess that's what i'm trying to
say and that's how i know that his isn't
either and when you check his financials
this actually becomes even more clear
because you might have been wondering
this whole time why is he raising 500
000
specifically at such an insane valuation
well
it has something to do with the fact i
think that he's 500 000
in debt
call it a crazy hunch uh but i found
this fact out at the bottom of his
financial document all the way down all
14 pages down the very last line you
will see this disrupt owes 466 thousand
dollars and they also owe attorney fees
so basically they owe 500 000 that's
what they say aka all of it
to pay off the debts so for those of you
who have been paying attention
forget about films forget about the
metaverse forget about virtual reality
your money is going off to pay
jack's dad and he's trying to sell all
of this to you as if it's some shiny
turd straight from mark zuckerberg's
metaverse and it's worth five hundred
thousand dollars but it isn't and here's
the thing it gets even worse because
wait till you hear how he got in debt in
the first place because it turns out
that jack had a co-founder this whole
time of disrupt who owned 50 of the
company and one day jack decides he's
gonna buy him out of his 50
for wait for it 500
000
so
yes you're hearing this right he bought
out fifty percent of disrupt for five
hundred thousand dollars and then is
selling his fans
ten percent of the company for the same
five hundred thousand dollars because he
can't afford the quarterly payments
obviously because he overpaid for it
which is very ironic and in all this he
tries to pretend it's about the
metaverse and hides the actual financial
truth at the bottom of his disclosure
and by the way that disclosure that i'm
telling you guys about the really
important one um it's not in his video
and it's actually at the very bottom of
his crowdfunding website so all you have
to do to learn about the super important
fact is go into the link scroll to the
very bottom get that document go to the
very bottom of that document and finally
you could learn the truth guys are you
not seeing how big of a scam this is i
mean to be clear i have no problem if
people want a crowdfund for really
anything as long as they're honest if he
told people hey i'm in debt and i'm
trying to raise money for it i ain't got
no problem with that but he doesn't tell
you that because of obviously you're not
gonna spend money on his bad financial
decisions you're gonna spend money if
you think you're building the future and
you think you're getting rich which i
guess you are building the future but
it's just it's just jack's future which
you know is different i did reach out to
disrupt to ask if there's some context
that i'm missing here and so far i've
gotten no response but on discord he has
been answering some questions so i want
to go over that apparently the full
story is that jack says that his
co-owner originally bought disrupt 50 of
it anyways for 10 000 a while ago and
jack seems to have done most of the work
in the interim this co-founder then
turned into some super garyvee villain
and wanted to turn everything into nfts
and sell crypto coins and jack was
against it because he didn't want you
investing in bad financial decisions um
and so he wanted a buyout and he got
about for 500 000
but it's here where things start to get
complicated because when jack started
throwing his partner under the bus as
some nft super villain his partner
decided to climb from underneath it and
clear his name he jumped in the discord
and started disproving the claims one by
one starting with crypto he says hi
there i am the partner with significant
creative differences spoiler there was
mention of a disrupt crypto coin or
slinging nfts i think that's a misguided
interpretation of my vision and that's
not the only thing that might be untrue
remember jack said that his partner only
invested 10k but it turns out it was a
lot more than that quote i invested a
lot more than 10k into disrupt that is
another point that requires
clarification 10k was initial bankroll
but the major investment came from three
years of salaries being paid overhead
rent for office space studio equipment
etc we later learned that he probably
invested around two hundred thousand
dollars because he says the 500k buyout
was a little over a 2x on his investment
which he rightfully points out is a
terrible return on a youtube channel
investment where mostly your dollars
would go to zero so it turns out jack's
co-founder isn't some predatory lending
supervillain nor was it true when jack
said that his co-founder even asked for
the buyout or set the conditions quote
just as another note i never wanted to
sell my stake in the company jack
offered the valuation i did not set it
there that was his offer that i accepted
in an effort to resolve amicably now
this all contradicts what jack has said
directly in a follow-up video that he
did after i reached out to him he said
his co-founder is the one who set the
price this is where the 466 thousand
dollars of debt can be seen on our
financials this is what the prior member
has set their price at in order to
depart from disrupt so who's telling the
truth here well it looks like it's not
jack because recently he's deleted his
comment saying his co-founder only put
in 10k and that his co-founder set the
price instead he changed it to this
quote i have updated the previously
typed message in 2017 a co-founder and i
started disrupt as an llc in 2021 we
settled on a buyout agreement now what i
find crazy about this is that while
changing his story jack doesn't
acknowledge what he's changing here
because remember we've gone from the
co-founder is a villainous nft huckster
who bought his company for ten thousand
dollars and demanded a buyout for 500k
now it's looking like his co-founder
invested two hundred thousand dollars
didn't push nfts and didn't even want to
be bought out and look i'm not here to
settle who's right in their business
disagreements i i just don't even care
i'm just here to point out that jack is
disguising his business problems as
financial opportunities which they're
not and when he gets caught he continues
to lie and throws his co-founder under
the bus when it just seems like they
basically have creative differences i
don't know it just seems like jack is
acting like one of these delusional
people who go on shark tank with five
dollars in sales and are seeking a
million dollars for one percent of their
company except for the fact instead of
pitching to mark cuban he's pitching to
his fans who might not know why it's a
bad investment because he's deliberately
hid it from them but luckily people are
finally figuring out what he did and
he's rightfully getting ripped apart by
his audience for it and that's kind of
the good news that he's unlikely to
reach his goal and the other good news
is that plan b isn't that big of a deal
the co-founder would get 51 of the
company and it seems like he doesn't
want to do that much different jack
would continue producing content fans
don't lose money and things just return
back to the status quo honestly this is
just such a stupid drama for no reason
jack decided to swindle his fans out of
500k because he didn't like his
co-founder by selling them a company at
an even worse price than he bought it
for and by the way remember he can't pay
the debt because obviously it was a
terrible decision and when he gets got
trying to sell this bad debt he doubles
down and tries to tell everyone that
he's saving the company from his
co-founder who by all accounts seems
like a pretty nice guy and yet has there
ever been an apology
no and for all these reasons the crazy
valuation the bad debt the lies i'm out